there's a movement on the right about
racism which sort of range is from
there's no such thing as racism - we
should never accuse anyone of being
racist - you can never really know if
someone is racist well there's a West
Virginia official who will now be one
who has resigned and another one who has
been put on leave because of a reference
to Michelle Obama the first lady as an
ape in heels I'm referring to pamela
ramsey taylor the director of the Clay
County Development Corp which provides
services to elderly and low-income
residents the mayor of Clay West
Virginia has also resigned as a result
of this and she was celebrating the
victory of Donald Trump in the
presidential election and the elevation
of Melania Trump to first lady which is
very very scary to a lot of people and
she wrote it will be so refreshing to
have a classy beautiful dignified first
lady back in the White House I'm tired
of seeing a ape in heels not an ape but
a ape Beverly wailing the mayor of Clay
responded on Facebook by saying that
just made my day Pam the mayor really
really liking this a petition calling
for wailing to be fired received more
than 120 1000 signatures as of midday
yesterday in her own apology the mayor
denied that her sentiments were racist
bear in mind 121 thousand signatures the
town of Clay has a population of 491
people none of whom are black according
to the latest census Clay County has
9,000 people 0.2% of which are black can
we say that this is a racist woman I
mean I get that there's this movement
pat of we can never call anyone racist
because you never know what it is that
that they're actually thinking if the
first way that comes to mind to
criticize Michelle Obama is as an ape in
heels maybe you're a little bit racist
yeah we can tell what they're thinking
based on the words that come out of
their mouth and you gotta love how she
gave this non apology saying that she's
sorry to anyone that she offends I'll of
course have to own up to what you what
you did if you're gonna be give a true
apology I love those apologies Rachel
where the
is if anybody was offended it's an
apology but not I said something
absolutely horrible and there's no
excuse or justification whatsoever and
people are talking about free speech
right everybody anytime something like
this happens people start talking about
free speech I believe in free speech and
I believe it is absolutely fine to post
this on Facebook and to say it and for
the mayor to say wow what a breath of
fresh air I really like what you're
saying I also believe that you are not
immune to the consequences of your
speech when we talk about free speech in
the First Amendment the government can't
prevent you from stating your opinions
everybody here rachel stated their
opinions and those opinions have
consequences yeah and you have to be
cognizant of when you're putting
something on a public platform as a
public official you are probably going
to receive some attention on it even if
it's something positive or something
negative and it's really again no
surprise that he won 77% of the vote
there but another interesting thing that
I was kind of thinking about is I feel
like this election and we've seen we're
now seeing this time and time again has
brought out really the absolute kind of
worst in humanity in terms of all of the
racism and anti-semitism that we're
seeing which is in stark contrast to
what we saw when Obama was elected and
we kind of I saw a lot of the opposite
well what's fascinating is President
Obama is elected and there is record
racial and identity based attacks
against him and then now that the
president no longer is the one with the
sort of non-agent identity the attacks
now are against other groups that really
are apparently upsetting to the Trump
supporters it's been sort of reversed
but in a way it's really just been a
redirection
of who is being attacked with these
ideas and the bottom line on this is if
you can't criticize a black person
without resorting to calling them Apes
maybe you've got something going on
racially there that you need to really
think about we're gonna take a break
next I will speak to Reed summers I
won't tell you more about this interview
but I think you will find it fascinating